(music ends) (clapping and cheering)
- Welcome to our show.
- Thank you. - We're so
stoked to have you here.
- It's so beautiful to be here.
Watching that scene,
right now, in the back
it just brought memories back
from what a beautiful life.
- Yeah. No, and it's, was
that really cool to be able to
speak in your native tongue
like on the show, like,
that's pretty cool.
- It was the most beautiful thing.
It was. - Yeah.
- And now I understand what Americans feel
like when they act in English.
- Yeah. (stutters)
- It's so much easier.
- They don't do it all the time.
So I thought it was really cool. - Yeah.
- And because of my Duolingo,
I understood most of it.
(audience laughs)
So very proud of myself.
- High-Five to that.
- Thank you. Thank you.
(audience cheers)
But you, you grew up in Guatemala.
I did not know this about
you because my sister
loves all the Chicago, she
loves all these. - Yeah.
- She's the one who watches
them in my house and I'm always
watching them with her.
So I didn't actually know
that you were a professional
soccer player at first.
- Yeah. I mean, I, yeah.
Soccer, that sport saved my life.
That was.. - Oh wow.
- That was, it got me
through the toughest times
in my childhood.
And I got recruited by the
AC Milan to go to Italy to
play soccer in Italy for a while.
- Yeah.
- Then I broke my femur
and then I shifted things
and became a martial artist.
And I learned Krav Maga became
a black belt in Krav Maga.
- Are You serious?
- Yeah. For real.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah.
- But it is interesting, like if you
if you say yes to things that
you might not have before
and then your life takes
you down a different path.
- Yes.
- So way better at life.
- It's way better.
- Yeah. And I'm glad you did
it cause you're so amazing
on this show.
- Thank you so much.
- And so when did you move to Los Angeles?
You were pretty young right?
- Yeah. Well, I was eight.
I was born and raised in Guatemala.
And at 18, after doing all these things
and I wanted to maybe go
to Israel, to the army.
- Yeah.
- I, I was like, I don't
know what to do, you know?
And I, I was, I was sitting
in that red light with my mom
right. True story.
And she's like, yeah, what should we do?
You know, you tried the soccer thing
you tried the Krav Maga
like, what can we do?
And she was like, wait,
you like movies, don't you?
And I was like, yeah. Yeah I like movies.
What do you mean "I like movies"?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Everyone likes movies.
She was like, "why don't you do that"?
And I was like what?
What, what do you mean?
- I love your mom.
- Yeah.
- She just like, sure, go do it.
- Yes. My mom is my angel and she was,
- That's amazing. - And she
and she literally told me that.
And I was like, well, how do you do that?
And she was like, well, I
guess you moved to Hollywood.
Right?
- I love your mom.
- And she was like, where is that?
I was like, it's in Los Angeles.
Yeah. So she, she said,
she said to me, you know
like Brad Pitt, like he, he packed his car
and he packed his bags and
he went to Hollywood do that.
And I was like
- Most parents are like,
have a backup plan.
- For real.
- Yeah. That's incredible.
- And we just shook it
and we were like, we're going
to Hollywood. - I love it.
- Yeah. And I called the airline that day
and I never went back for 10 years.
One way ticket to LA.
- You're always gonna have
this belief in yourself
because you had such a
great mother to instill
that in you too.
Cause she had so much belief in you
what a beautiful mother you have. Wow.
- I have the story of a
single mother of my angel.
That is my story.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yes. Yes.
- You are welcome here.
Anytime. I just cried almost.
Okay, we're fine.
(audience laughs)
So let's talk about your show.
- Okay. - So tell everybody who you play.
- Well, I play Dante Torres,
(audience cheers)
- aka Ocean.
And he is, he comes
from a tough environment
but he's always maintained
his heart and his integrity
is what he is.
And he knows exactly who he is.
He's not a people pleaser at all.
And he will do right by what he believes
100%, all in all the time you know.
- What a great character.
- It's a beautiful character.
I was blessed to have
this beautiful character.
- And I, he's taught
me so much to me, like
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
I've learned so much from him, you know?
- That's so cool. - Yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] So a
lot of my staff is actually
from Chicago. No joke.
And they say that there's something called
a Chicago handshake.
- Yes. And I, I have some...
- [Kelly Clarkson]
You've experienced this?
- I have something for you.
- Okay. Is this the handshake?
- Yes. - Is this what it is?
- Yes. The shot of Malort.
- What's a Malort?
What's a, what's Malort?
- Malort is,
- Is it a liquor? - A type of alcohol.
- Okay. - From Chicago that I
you can only drink this if you're cool.
- Okay. - But
- No peer pressure,
- But. - No. -But
So I drank it in Chicago.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- [Benjamin Levy Aguilar]
Cause I'm cool like that.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- [Benjamin Levy Aguilar]
And I think you're cool too.
- I'm Pretty cool. I think so.
- [Benjamin Levy Aguilar] So
- [Kelly] Tell everyone.
- [Benjamin Levy Aguilar] What we do here.
- [Kelly Clarkson] This
is the shot of Malort?
- This is the shot of Malort.
- Malort. Okay.
- And then we chase it down with beer.
- You do the shot and you
chase, it's a chaser. Okay.
- Yeah. And then we shake on
it and now we're cool together.
- Okay.
- Ready? - I think we been
cool either way, but cool.
Let's do it. - All right.
- Okay. Wait. Cheers.
- Cheers. - I love you.
- L'Chayim. - L'Chayim.
(crowd cheers)
- You don't need a chaser.
- You don't need a chaser?
- That's good!
I don't think I needed a chaser.
Oh, it's still hot going down
- For me. It's like very bitter.
It's like very bitter
- Right? - I don't know.
I think it's like people
like you like beets
or you don't like certain
things like certain
- Sure. I get Do you think
that's an acquired taste?
- Nah, I'd just handle it.
(laughter)